أدى الشهران الأولان من الحرب إلى تدمير
نظام الرعاية الصحية في غزة، حيث شنت إسرائيل هجومًا جويًا ثم بريًا
على شمال
القطاع من أصل 22 مستشفى في شمال
غزة. وقد حددت شبكة سي إن إن 20 مستشفى
تعرضت للأضرار أو دمرت في الفترة ما بين
7 أكتوبر و7 ديسمبر.
من قبل سي إن إن يظهر أن أكثر من نصفهم قد
تعرضوا لهجوم مباشر، بما في ذلك
أكبر اثنتين في غزة، وقد تعرض ألفا وإلس
لهجوم مباشر من قبل
قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية، وتشير هذه الأدلة إلى أن
مستشفى آل سي إن وجدت سابقًا
أدلة على أن صاروخًا تم إطلاقه بشكل غير صحيح من غزة كان على
الأرجح مسؤولاً عن انفجار مميت،
ولكن  يبدو أن هذا هو الاستثناء الذي
يطلق عليه المستشفى القطري وتقول إسرائيل
والمخابرات الأمريكية إن حماس استخدمت العديد
من هذه المستشفيات
كمراكز قيادة وسيطرة وتزعم لجنة التنسيق الإدارية أن حماس تنفي
بينما تحميها
القانون الإنساني الدولي، فإن حماية المستشفى
أثناء الحرب ليست مطلقة، وهناك
حالات حيث هؤلاء  يمكن
فقدان الحماية وهذا هو الوقت الذي يتم فيه
استخدامها أه
للأنشطة العسكرية لتعزيز
الأنشطة أه أه عدو
لا يعطي حرية مطلقة للجيوش أه
لشن هجوم كيفما أه يريدون
هذا هو ال  ثاني أكبر
مستشفى في غزة، قمنا بتصميم نموذج لأسابيع من
الهجمات الإسرائيلية، حيث تسببت في
أضرار جسيمة وأذى للمدنيين خلف
المستشفى في 29 أكتوبر،
وقد
أصاب انفجار للتو مدير Alud الذي تحدث إلى CNN
في ذلك اليوم قائلًا إنه كان هناك قصف في كل مكان
حولنا في نوفمبر  في السابع من الشهر الجاري، نشر جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي مقطع
فيديو لهم وهم ينفذون غارة على بعد
100 متر فقط من مدخل المستشفى هنا،
وزعموا أنهم كانوا يستهدفون
مستودع أسلحة تابع لحماس، ويبدو أن الضربة قد
حدثت في الخامس من نوفمبر/تشرين الثاني، ويظهر هذا الفيديو
من الأرض أشخاصًا
ممددين بعيدًا عن المكان.  المشهد وإلى
المستشفى ولكن الداخل بدا
هكذا بالفعل بعد أيام من الضربات
القريبة، يقول الجيش الإسرائيلي إنهم طلبوا من الناس مرارًا وتكرارًا
إجلاء الطاقم الطبي بالداخل
في ذلك الوقت، وقالوا إن هذا لم يكن
ممكنًا، لدينا آلاف الأشخاص
للذهاب إلى الخارج حيث
للذهاب، قال المستشار القانوني للجيش الإسرائيلي لشبكة CNN إنهم
لم يهاجموا مستشفى إل إلا في
منتصف نوفمبر/تشرين الثاني عندما ردوا على ما يبدو بإطلاق
النار من مسلحي حماس الذين نشروا هذه
اللقطات كدليل على مقتل 21 شخصًا،
وقالت قوات الدفاع الرواندية إنهم إرهابيون
لكنهم اعترفوا بأن المدنيين ما زالوا
بالداخل في مستشفى ألفا.
كان المدنيون النازحون يحتمون في
الفناء حيث
تكثفت الهجمات الجوية، وقال مستشار قانوني للجيش الإسرائيلي لشبكة CNN مرة أخرى
إنهم لم يهاجموا إيليفا، لكن
خبراء الأسلحة قالوا لشبكة CNN إن هذه
بقايا قذيفة مضيئة إسرائيلية
بعد بضع ساعات، وقد
تعرض جناح الولادة للقصف هنا.  تم العثور على صاروخ دبابة إسرائيلية
في غضون أسبوع القوات الإسرائيلية تدخل
المستشفى لا يمكننا أن نرى أه فحص
وتفتيش الجزء
من
المستشفى كانت ألفا أحد المستشفيات التي
يقول الجيش الإسرائيلي والولايات المتحدة إن حماس كانت
تعمل فيها ولكن عندما وصلت القوات
يبدو أنهم لم يجدوا سوى القليل من
الأدلة على نشر مقاطع الفيديو هذه
لشبكة من الأنفاق، ما
لم تظهره مقاطع فيديو جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي هو ما
كانوا سيجدونه على بعد أمتار فقط من
المقابر المتعددة التي حفرها المدنيون الذين
أجبروا على دفن أحبائهم
داخلها.  أرض المستشفى وسط
الحصار المستمر، المصور يسأل من
في القبر، أمي
تجيب، هل يمكنني أن أروي لك
محادثة أجريتها مع مستشار قانوني
للجيش الإسرائيلي قالوا لي في نهاية
اليوم ما دامت حماس  إذا استمر
استخدام هذه المستشفيات والمرافق في
العمليات العسكرية،
فلا يوجد أي خيار على الإطلاق سوى الذهاب إلى هناك، فهذا خيار
مطلق وتأطيره
ليس كخيار هو تأطير ذلك
الموت والدمار على أنه مجرد
حتمية خلال الشهرين الأولين من الحرب.
أصبحت الحرب الآن من بين أكثر الصراعات فتكًا
وتدميرًا من أي صراع في
التاريخ الحديث، ويظل السؤال حول
ما إذا كان أي هدف عسكري يمكن أن
يبرر
هذا الأمر.